Das war's für heute.
Leider neither war's imancen,
Fr vo der
Das war's für heute.
turkey
Sieht cool aus.
Und jetzt müssen wir eigentlich nur noch stretch.
OBS please.
Jetzt sieht man wieder nur, ey ich krieg Anfälle, was ist das denn?
Das Problem ist, ihr denkt, dass es richtig ist, ist es nicht, weil ihr seht nur den Output. Bei mir ist das Spiel permanent im Fullscreen und OBS captures halt nur als keine Ahnung 400x300 Fenster oder so.
Und wenn ich das Fenster dann umschiebe, dann stimmt dann am Ende die Auflösung nicht mehr.
Ihr habt's gleich.
Ich will jetzt mal gucken, ob das so passt.
Ich hab jetzt nicht gedacht, dass es so ein großes Problem ist ehrlich gesagt.
So jetzt geh ich ins Game rein, mal gucken, ob's geht.
Okay, okay, okay, das sieht doch gut aus. So weiß jemand den Knopf, wie ich in OBS Fenster resize, ohne Ratio beizubehalten?
Also was muss ich da drücken? War das Alt oder was ist das?
Shift, Shift, Shift ist es.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir, ob's jetzt noch passt.
Ich muss jetzt wieder Fullscreen bei mir und gucken, ob's funktioniert.
Leute, wir nähern uns, easy.
So, mal gucken, ob jetzt noch alles stimmt. Wenn es jetzt stimmt, lass ich so, ich fass es nicht mehr an.
Jawoll, jawoll!
Leute, können wir so damit leben, ja?
Scheiß auf die, scheiß auf die Parenda.
Komm, Stückchen, in Stückchen war was noch.
Ich bin ja Perfektionist, was so was angeht.
Ja, jetzt ist es schön. Jetzt ist es schön. Okay, auf geht's.
Ich hab hier mal ein neues Android-Tablet übrigens am Start.
Ein Asus Zenpad 3S10. Nur mal so, weil wir Weihnachten haben.
Und für die Preis-Leistung muss ich sagen, finde ich das Ding echt cool.
Das Einzige, was mir echt auf den Sack geht, was ein ziemlicher Minuspunkt ist, das Ding ist verseucht mit irgendwelchen Asus-Apps.
Und bitte registrieren Sie sich und machen Sie sonst irgendeinen Kack.
Ich muss mal gucken, ob der jetzt System-Aktualisierung gemacht hat.
Hat er nicht.
Dann darf er jetzt nochmal updaten in der Zeit. Okay, fangen wir an.
Ist die Musik okay eigentlich von der Lautstärke? Oh, yes.
Bei einem Google-Handy alles mit Google.
Ich finde, die Google-Apps gehen noch, aber ich sag's euch mal, was da drauf ist.
Pass mal auf, das haltet euch mal fest. Das ist total übertrieben.
Oh, er lädt wieder System-Aktualisierung runter. Jetzt Android 7, glaube ich.
Da ist drauf die Zenpad-Pflege der Mobile Asus-Manager.
Es hängt.
Gallery-Datei-Manager, Asus-Fotokollage.
Es gibt sogar eine Asus-Wetter-App, was zum Teufel, was auch immer.
Dann ist drauf die Asus-Taschenlampe.
Der ZenUI-Launcher, Zenpad-Surface, Zen-Circle, Minimovie.
Das ist der Wahnsinn, wie vollgegleistert das mit Asus-Apps ist.
Und ich hab schon direkt am Anfang 130. Die Asus-App zeigt mir gerade an 130 Aktualisierungen für Asus-Apps.
Das muss man sich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen, 130. Was haben die da drauf alles?
Jetzt soll ich Start-Seite verwalten. Ich will meine Start-Seite nicht verwalten.
Ich will einfach ganz normales Tablet verwenden.
So, legen wir los. Starte das Abenteuer, jawoll.
Ich hätte mir am liebsten so ein ganz einfaches Android-Tablet gewünscht,
also wo einfach RAW-Android drauf ist und gut ist.
Jetzt müssen wir erstmal die Tutorial-Levels spielen. Das ist natürlich Absolut-Ease.
Was gab es denn Gutes zu futtern? Es gab Rotkraut, Nudeln und Rehfleisch.
Übelst nice. Ich schnall's. Reh.
Das Tablet. Wer hat dir denn das Tablet geschenkt? Das Tablet hat mir keiner geschenkt.
Das Tablet hab ich meiner Mutter geschenkt.
Aber nachdem du immer so was davor sitzt, nach dem Motto, was, Update, was macht es da? Mach du mal.
Mach ich halt mal.
Zombie-Kopf sieht ein bisschen gestretched aus.
Passt es von der Musik her eigentlich oder soll ich Weihnachtsmusik ausmachen
oder Plants vs. Zombies leiser? Weil Weihnachtsmusik und Plants vs. Zombies gedudelt.
Komm, wir machen jetzt mal die Musik aus.
Wir haben jetzt hier Frank Sinatra wieder laufen. Der hat's halt einfach drauf.
So stretched kann man sich das nicht geben. Jetzt hören wir aber auf.
Ich hab jetzt die erste halbe Stunde rumgefrickelt, bis das überhaupt funktioniert hat, dass es gestretched ist.
Soll ich das Bild, ihr entscheidet. Soll ich das Bild wieder ein bisschen unstretchen?
Oder wollen wir es verlassen?
Ich kann ein bisschen lauter machen, das kann ich machen.
Ich kann ein bisschen lauter machen.
Das ist schlimm.
Boah, es ist huge!
Oh, die weint schon, die Nuss!
Bible samt Nuss!
Wenn man schon, wenn man schon Emotionen in Twitch-Emoves kommuniziert, dann weiß man, dass man auch nicht mehr ganz richtig im Kopf ist!
Die Nuss...
Die Nuss braucht RGB-Beleuchtung!
Hahaha, das war ein guter Witz!
High Value-Nuss!
Bam!
Springen sie gegen die Wand?
Nice-Flammen-Boy-Stratz!
Das ist voll OP, diese Nuss!
Das ist voll OP, da kann keiner mehr drüberspringen, hat sau viel TP!
Was hatten wir doch gerade?
Achso, das läuft ja in Autoloop, hab ich ganz vergessen!
Oh, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt geht's aber ab hier!
Boom!
Zack! Boom!
Easy Hold!
First Point-Defense!
Minigame-Gedöns!
Ja, gut, dann kann ich jetzt Chat lesen, das ist ja meistens easy!
Die flammenden Boys machen 200% Schaden, aber ja, das lohnt sich echt!
Ja, Flammen-Boys!
Ich brauch jetzt irgendwas, um den zu bashen!
Mal gucken, was es noch gibt!
Santa Baby, so hurry down the chimney!
Santa Cutie, and fill my stocking with the booze!
Boah, ich hab mir noch überhaupt keine Gedanken zugemacht, ob ich mich da jetzt bewerbe, ob ich den von Twitch mal anschreibe!
Gar nicht! Also, weißt du, ich hab mir noch überhaupt keine Gedanken zugemacht!
Boom, boom, boom!
Ich will Geld rauswerfen, gut investieren, BOKAS!
Wir brauchen Kekse-Emoji, ja, das brauchen wir dann tatsächlich!
Also sollte ich Partner werden, dann nur, wenn ich, also was heißt nur, also das erste, was ich dann mache, ist ordentliche Kekse-Emoji besorgen!
Da muss man aber einen guten Designer für finden, nicht so einfach!
Alles Thumbnail-Designer haben sich bei mir als sehr unzuverlässig auf Dauer rausgestellt, das heißt, da braucht man dann irgendjemand, der da Erfahrungen mit hat!
Bringen zweimal Flammen-Boys hintereinander was? Wahrscheinlich nicht!
Braucht man Platt-Seerose als Flammen-Boy!
Platt!
Du musst kein Partner sein, um Subs anbieten zu können, ja, ich weiß, ich könnte auch Affiliate-Zeug machen, aber wenn schon, dann mach ich das richtig!
Da gibt es dann wenigstens auch ordentlich Emotes, also auch ordentliche Menge!
Ich krieg grad schon auf den Sack die Zombies!
Ich bin ein unvergesslicher Nader!
Keine Ahnung, brauch ich das?
Ich pflanze einfach nur sinnlose Zeugs wohin!
Ich bin ein unvergesslicher Nader!